[Applause]
oh Jos is a Dan arm I'm dancing feels
good dancing feels so nice yes we're
here in person with you I know and
welcome to New York how do you like it I
love it my hands are cold I'm sorry well
cuz you're in New York it I know I love
it though the layering the fall W
beautiful time of year I'm so excited to
have you both here you so excited that
you're having us here Andrew didn't want
to do it and I was like we have
to I I I pissed him off in the
zoom who chose to do the kid photos on
the playbow I love that we we did it
together we did it together cuz we were
talking so cuz the whole thing is about
dreams right it's about yeah dreams can
you guys guess which one is
which um well no we were talking about
the you know first of all we were asked
to pick head shots for the play bill
which I don't know about you but I hate
pick pictures I got in the wrong line of
work I hate just I'm like I don't I
don't so then we were talking about it
and I was like we should use kid
pictures because it is about two guys
who have this dream taking a show to
Broadway and that's around the age that
we both sort of discovered that that's
what we wanted to do we wanted to be
actors and we wanted to you know to be
on Broad you got the bug yeah so we we
chose those photos instead to be fair we
did those pictures as kids knowing that
one day they would be used as head shots
for Gutenberg the so it was very for
thinking we really ahead we're long
plann we're planners I know I like that
about you so wa you knew like what what
hit you like what did you see that you
knew you wanted to be in musical theater
or in entertainment in general oh man I
I you know I saw Peter Pan with Kathy
Rigby when I was about 5 years old on
tour and I said one day I'm not going to
be able to play that part but I'd like
to play something
else very self-aware at a young age you
knew what your limitations were yeah
well I it took me a second to find
musical theater but my what I wanted to
be first was a solid gold dancer a solid
gold dancer yes does anyone remember
solid oh I was like that was very
specific it was a variety show they had
dancers I wanted to do that and then I
realized that there's actually like a
different job called an actor yeah where
you could do musicals and I started
watching the Tony Awards and then that
really then I got I got in trouble as a
kid because I was a big performer even
as a child so I walked my mom got called
to the school one day because I as a
kindergartener I would apparently
walking to the class late what
kindergardener walks in late so this all
this all tracks this all tracks and I
would and I would apparently open the
door look at my teacher and go
hiot and they called my mom to the
school or I would say or I would hauts
or Lucy I'm
home was apparently not okay you were a
born performer I was a born perform
amazing you're reminding me my son that
is so my son Remy because he had a very
horrible
future no he's he's that kind of
entertaining though he's a sponge he
watches something he loves it he just it
comes he regurgitates it yeah it's
awesome it's a curse so wait so
Halloween it's not a it's a blessing
it's a blessing it's a blurst it's a
blur it's a BL um it's both so Halloween
is coming up I know you got kiddos um so
so what do y'all do you do you dress cuz
I I know that we had the cute little
photos of your children but I also found
this one of you and I just have a quick
question Andrew
um like what I don't know that I've ever
known a kid that dresses as the Pope the
pop yeah you're a very serious kid it
was a very Catholic idea my brother and
his family are here so he was wit to
this what family hi um so yeah my
grandma Josephine had this idea that I
was going to be the pope so she put
together that costume she got me and I
was the pope and my little sister
Natalie was an angel but it was like but
it's still like hands down I'm 45 that's
my best Halloween costume oh my God I
love you the PO fourth grade can you
imagine trick- or- tree I've just never
seen a kid dress as the pope as the pope
it was I was very popular espe like Tony
Stark very popular people took a lot of
pictures me it was like yeah I felt you
were a hit I was a hit okay well I have
to pull this one up to this was last
year and this was incredible yes this
was this is
incredible I mean lots of in what's
really what's really complicated what's
really complicated about this picture is
I was also trying to be the
pope it is tricky they're layers some
something went very wrong someone LED
you astray no I lost a bet with my
daughters I lost a bet they said if you
lose this bet you have to be Ursula for
Halloween and so I ended up being Ursula
for Halloween please tell me you walked
around trick-or-treating with them
singing Poor Unfortunate Souls 100% okay
you would have let me down oh yeah do
you like to dress up
love to dress up I love a theme I don't
even want to go to a party unless it's
themed like like why hang out like to go
to any parties unless they're themed or
just Halloween I me let's beat I I'm
sorry I can't attend your wedding unless
everybody's dressed up as a character I
did wait I did throw a themed party one
time though and andri glacia showed up
and because we had the same manager at
the time I don't hang out with famous
people I'm not cool and I but he showed
up and he wasn't in costume and at that
point I'd had a lot to drink and so I
was very bold and walked up and was like
get out you know I'm a
c I was like you have to wear a costume
to be here and I was like I'm just
kidding but kind of get out I like also
get a costume I Can't Rap it says rap
and there's nothing but I will make up
nothing to R okay I was like it says rap
and I was like I don't know if you've
noticed nothing rap you can toally I
cannot rap did you do hi we'll be back
after this break
so I'm not just saying this I've
literally heard so much because
everybody here also talks about shows
right non-stop which I love but
everybody is talking about Gutenberg the
musical so how where did they your show
you're in it too look Josh that's us
that's us you are about two men and one
dream no chance I like it says it all
right there that's it that's all you
need to know so what do people need to
know like coming in H or do you want
them to know well we're in it well no so
so it's about two guys named Bud and
Doug who have decided they're sort of
new fans of musical theater they they
want to write a musical they want to
write a hit musical so they decide that
um a historical musical can I just say
you're doing great right now thank you
very much a historical musical those do
well so they pick um to write a musical
about Johan Gutenberg the inventor of
the printing press cuz isn't that like a
fun sexy idea I have a quicker pitch
which is it's a Hamilton of Our
Generation
no Josh I've I've explained this Josh
many times Hamilton is the Hamilton of
Our Generation Hamilton it's the other
Hamilton of Our Generation the other one
we are no we're having we're having the
best time ranold and I the last time I
was on Broadway was over a decade ago I
I've been when we did a book of Mormon
together and I've I've been wanting to
come back thank you so much so good and
I've been wanting to come back and I
wanted I only really wanted to come back
with him cuz he's the only person who
would perform with me well work with and
so I and finally the trining orders
right now yeah yeah then I was able to
back on St physically we could work
together again um but it's it's been you
know the world needs some laughter right
now it's it's a it's a it's a it's a sad
time in the world and and it's been
really refreshing to be able to provide
people with that sense of just two hours
of escapism and we get to be idiots and
we we play each of us plays about 20
characters we have 150 hats that we wear
in this show literal hats literal hats
Lal hats I hear that it's chaos
backstage is this true I can't imagine
it is well this is this is a strange
show because we're on stage the entire
time like once Josh and I go out there
oh so there's no break what if you have
to pee that's we do it on stage well
there's an inter okay okay Josh where's
the diaper well actually by the way I
wear a man diaper in the show would you
like to explain this so I want I want to
tell you guys when we first started
doing the show I had my shirt tucked in
and every time I danced it would come up
would come up and you would just see too
much of my body and so they they said to
me we have to we have to button you into
your pants now now the technical term
for this is a crotch strap okay but but
the but the untechnical term for it is a
pain in the ass because I have to
basically wear this diaper that I'm
fastened into so he's wearing a onesie
and sometimes I and sometimes you know
before show you need to go number two or
four Joshua yeah we all got it's you
want to feel lighter a safe this is a
safe I
comfortable in order to do what I need
to do as a human I have to have a grown
man unbutton 20 buttons I don't I don't
help with this this is not but Andrew
watches and I do watch
it I watch like that so wait have you
had a moment cuz I've had moments on
tour where I'm like on stage and I'm
like I had a moment during Book of
Mormon where I lit I felt my stomach
drop oh no I was like and the sweat the
one the sweat started coming and the
audience was like why does that
character look so uncomfortable um you
made it through well I had I literally
remember I was timing I had a minute and
a half there was a bathroom right next
to this is this is not where I wanted
this this is really taking a turn I'm
just saying you already you were already
wearing a diaper this is my fault and I
apologize to everyone watching we'll
just but the diaper is part of it's part
of the glamour of Broadway yeah um how
you've been friends for so long now is
it you tolerate each other you've
tolerated each other for at least a
decade sure sure so wait are there times
because it is it is a hard industry and
I think everybody always thinks we're
all barbecuing together all the time but
sometimes you don't like I don't have a
lot of friends that are like sometimes
we sa
together so wait do you have like those
times though is it it seems like that
kind of friendship that you can connect
when you're like man this is hard like
when you're being serious well we went
you know doing the Book of Mormon
together obviously we we could not have
predicted that that show would have been
as successful as it was really yeah I
mean I thought it was going to close
within three we were sort of all nervous
about have no pulse on the people yeah
but we um but by the way I thought
Frozen was going to be a bomb too I was
like about what do I know so Josh you
really yeah youve put your finger on the
pulse um but we got to go through that
whole experience together we went
through the Tony Awards together we both
moved back to Los Angeles together we
both had TV shows together they both got
cancelled together like we got to go
through all of it best of friends we do
everything and I could and you know I
could look at Josh and be like oh you
know exactly what I'm going through
right which is hard to describe to
people it's very rare it's very and we
we we really now you know over a decade
into this relationship we know when the
other person is like needs space from
like everybody encroaching on us so it's
like need a snack sometimes he needs
sometimes he gets angry and I'm like
vvus is about to burst I need to protect
the citizens of Pompei I need to protect
all the citizens of Pompei right now
give Drew 5 minutes he needs a cracker
he needs a cracker yes Shelby needs his
juice vice versa you we both sort of we
protect each other in a way that is like
that only comes with time and barbecuing
together which we need to do that we've
never done that we need to do that oh
look at this moments three of us are
going to barbecue I love barbecue don't
invite me yeah we're going to do it bris
it'll be bris it'll be a themed barbecue
themed I won't show up unless there's we
have a theme party we'll come back for a
cooking s we have to dress up Toy Story
[Music]
[Applause]
character thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home